hello and welcome to this video thing I
am all guns blazing splash crossbar oh
okay Fleck change is he wasn't playing
under UK flag all the time what's now
all I can just take but 97 or something
a bit more interesting but he's got
these three so i probably should take
yeah just normal development please for
black gets not easy to maintain the
center so i take and do now play for
Bishop to e5 the idea is that the d2
ball is just backward this should be a
good central set up for for black so he
tries to attack this immediately okay
letters are necessary move in the number
i anyway let's do it
[Music]
yeah so white has an active look
somewhat active looking position but
it's got a couple of weaknesses I'd see
probably be should be six here I just go
with the eight and try to do something
against his central formation
threatening Bishop takes you for now
that would completely it can take now or
is he having something special now okay
yeah it was amazed how quickly this
disease decisions are made okay you
should have seven King age eight ok
really why can you do that because it
takes only eight down ok or what is the
deal thinking of that is a far too many
year twenty pins going on queen of three
you didn't see that one
nothing good hello okay yeah that I
pictured a bit differently absolutely
yeah so I just get to get two pawns on
for that for the piece which is clearly
not enough ok check
h 6o g 6 from the h6 check okay oh yeah
that was great this is the great game
why did I play all that rubbish
sometimes you really want them now it's
pretty terrible
[Music]
why does he give me that I don't
understand said what is the deal here
okay I'm defending this here
ok cannot win unfortunately this until a
it's still a draw ok check ok
what was a real game pain drawing what I
Claire was complete rubbish by both
sides Williams but what's what going was
going on there and what is that you just
switched his on in the first place not
wanted what the wacky game I really
thought that that was nice them and I'm
pretty okay with this I don't think like
is fine him and then I was I was
completely not seeing that he has clean
up three then the floor guy doesn't work
just doesn't work at all here can and
then yeah even context before is good
how has complete rubbish I headed there
was a complete rubbish idea to take on
c4 okay I didn't even see that one I
mean our complete completely crazy and
now i'm totally all stores check check
check check 30 g gave in to the bishop
for absolutely no reason can you know
i'm defending this easily yeah there was
some kind of hallucination maybe you
just forgot to to to play this check
fluid i don't know i mean he never
slowed down ever with ya ok yeah it's
still easy to do i cannot do anything
unfortunately with my extra porn winning
would have been a bit much chef i mean
that that that's clear ok thanks for
watching this